america became
a more dangerous place in 2020 murders
were
up 30 percent across the country led by
democrat-run cities like chicago new
york and seattle
oakland california is currently
terrorized by an outbreak of random
attacks and robberies and things have
gotten
so bad that people have started citizen
patrols to keep their neighbors safe
but will this kind of vigilante law
enforcement
save lives or lead to more violence
joining me now is radio
host from seattle uh jason rantz
and jason uh
basically there are places where you
have one day of action january the sixth
and the world has to stop while we
address that find out who did it
and then there are these other places
where violence can just go on
day after day night after night for
months on end and it's just a normal
feature
of life out on the west coast
particularly
yeah and it's a sad reality for a lot of
people who live in these cities who have
to deal with it
citizens should not have to create their
own patrols be it in
oakland or anywhere else they should
have a
fully resourced police department to do
the work for them
this is not safe on the one hand i do
appreciate people going out into the
community because the more people who
are visible
who show up and say they care the better
it is but these are not folks who are
trained these are people who do not know
how to de-escalate
which is exactly what the activist
community has been demanding
so unfortunately it could end poorly for
these individuals who obviously are well
intentioned
what we need to stop doing is embracing
this
culture that has been attacking police
and policing because when you look
specifically at what's going on
in the city of oakland that's exactly
what's happened
you've had a murder last month every
other
day in the city of oakland and what's
happened at the exact same time
you've had a city that has embraced the
defund police movement
what have they done they've cut the
bicycle and foot patrols
they've cut the community resource teams
that patrol the neighborhoods
huh kind of weird yeah it is
it is weird we were talking uh shannon
bremen a couple of minutes ago
about incitement and one of the things
that's happening in these
lawless cities is that uh some of these
anti-trump groups
are now inciting the mob against you in
particular
yes they are i mean they do it to a lot
of folks who actually
go into the mob when they're out there
out on the streets and they're
committing their acts of vandalism and
other violence
we go in because we think it's actually
important to tell people what's going on
we know that a lot of media outlets are
not going to do that we know that there
are
media outlets like the competition that
pretend it doesn't actually exist
they're the arm of the democratic party
but it does exist
it is happening and what they end up
doing is people online notice that when
we're there we take photos and videos
they end up screenshotting our faces and
telling people our names
and hashtagging codes to the mob on the
ground saying hey
jason ranz is out there he's there
taking photos of your faces
be on the lookout and i was there just a
couple weeks ago
in the city of tacoma washington as part
of one of their riots
i heard my name being discussed i
thankfully was
undercover in the sense that we're in
the middle of a pandemic so i can cover
my face
i had a beanie on you couldn't really
tell it was me but i mean
they do that with the intent to harass
intimidate
and yes i've seen folks who are trying
to uncover this
sort of thing getting assaulted
yeah do you feel it's a little bit odd
when you have congressman
sobbing on the floor of the house of the
rep house of representatives
because they were you know three blocks
away on january the sixth but they
feel that somehow they're suffering from
post-traumatic stress disorder
while guys like you out on the streets
of american cities who are actually
being targeted
you're just supposed to suck it up
basically
yeah the thing of the here's the issue
they want to pretend
that because they have felt a trauma
that nothing else is going on that this
is just about them
there is no doubt that what happened on
january 6 was serious
and it is a stain on our history however
there was also eight months of violence
that has overtaken american cities
people were murdered businesses were
destroyed
lives were ruined and that also matters
we have to pay attention to that and to
this day
not only is that being ignored we still
have members of congress
like corey bush who are egging it on
that has to be seen as a potential
threat
right you're absolutely right jason
it'll it all seems to have to do oddly
enough
with which mob you happen to line up
with and their mobs get a very different
deal from officialdom
uh than the other guy's mobs thank you
for that uh jason always good to hear
from you and stay
safe on the mean streets of democrat
cities